We chose Shenzhen really because it's the capital for hardware.
All the suppliers are here.
You've got an ecosystem of both manufacturers and also, critically, engineering expertise.
Thirty years ago, the southern Chinese city bordering Hong Kong was just a sleepy fishing village.
But now Shenzhen has become a metropolis with 11 million people...
...since its designation as China's first special economic zone in 1980.
It is home to some of China's most successful tech companies like Huawei, Tencent and DJI.
Almost 40,000 foreign invested companies also set foot here.
When I first came here, it was generally senior engineers...
...that were working for large American or European companies.
That's completely changed.
But what you tend to get more of is the younger entrepreneurial or the R&D engineers...
...that are here to kinda create the next product.
Your computer, phone or TV probably got started in Shenzhen.
In 2015 alone, the city exported electronic equipment...
...in part with a total value of 29 billion US dollars.